- 양자 정보와 계산의 이해에
다시 오신 것을 환영해요.
저는 John Watrous이고
IBM Quantum Education의 기술 디렉터예요.
이번은 시리즈의 세 번째 수업이에요. 처음 두 수업에서는 양자 정보의
기초에 대해 이야기했어요.
먼저 단일 시스템을 독립적으로 살펴보고, 그다음에 다중 시스템을 다뤘어요.
또한 표준 기저 측정과
유니터리 연산에 대해서도 단일 시스템과
다중 시스템 환경 모두에서 논의했어요.
이번 수업에서는 quantum circuit 모델을
소개할 거예요. 이것은 양자 계산을 설명하는 표준적인 방법을 제공해요.
그리고 quantum circuit을 사용해서 양자 프로토콜과 여러 양자 장치를 포함하는 다양한 종류의 상호작용을 설명할 수도 있어요.
quantum circuit 외에도, 양자 정보와
관련된 몇 가지 중요한 수학적 개념도 논의할 거예요.
그리고 이를 사용해서 양자 정보의
몇 가지 근본적인 한계와 quantum circuit으로 할 수 있는 것들을 살펴볼 거예요.
이것은 다음 수업을 위한 좋은 준비가 될 거예요.
다음 수업에서는 매우 중요한 몇 가지 예제를 보고
시리즈의 첫 번째 단원을 마무리할 거예요.
양자 정보의 기초에 대한 내용이에요.
수업의 개요는 이래요. quantum circuit 모델부터 시작해서 어떻게 작동하는지 알아볼 거예요.
그다음에 매우 중요한 개념인
내적에 대해 이야기하고, 직교정규성과 사영에 대해서도 다룰 거예요.
이것들은 내적과 관련이 있어요. 처음 두 수업에서는
이런 것들을 논의하지 않았는데, 정말로 필요하지 않았기 때문이에요. 하지만 이제는 필요해요.
내적은 없으면 안 되는
수학적 도구를 제공해요.
내적 없이는 양자 정보와
계산을 이해하는 데 멀리 나아갈 수 없어요.
수업의 세 번째 부분에서는 양자 정보의
몇 가지 중요한 한계를 살펴볼 거예요.
궁극적으로 우리가 하고 싶은 것은 양자 정보로
할 수 있는 흥미로운 것들을 탐구하는 것인데, 이를 효과적으로 하려면
할 수 없는 것들에 대해서도
알아야 해요.
특히 글로벌 위상의 개념과
글로벌 위상이 왜 관련이 없는지에 대해 논의할 거예요.
복제 불가능 정리의 설명도 볼 거예요.
이것은 양자 상태를 일반적으로 복사할 수 없다는 것을 알려주고, 두 양자 상태가
직교하지 않으면 완벽하게
구별할 수 없다는 것도 볼 거예요. 이것은 알아두어야 할 근본적인 한계예요.
수업의 첫 번째 주제는
quantum circuit 모델이에요. 이것은 양자 계산을
설명하는 방법을 제공하는 계산 모델이에요.
양자 계산을 설명하는 거예요.
quantum circuit 모델은 컴퓨터 과학에서
circuit이라는 더 일반적인 개념에 기반하고 있고, 이 일반적인 개념을 바탕으로 많은
다양한 계산 모델을 정의할 수 있어요.
이 일반적인 개념에 기반해서요.
기본 아이디어는 circuit이 정보를 전달하는
와이어와 연산을 나타내는 gate로 구성된다는 거예요.
와이어가 전달하는 정보에
연산이 적용되는 거예요.
circuit이라는 용어는 사실
이런 종류의 모델에 사용하기에는 좀 이상한 이름이에요. 왜냐하면 circuit이라는 단어는
보통 어떤 종류의
순환 경로를 의미하거든요.
하지만 계산 모델로서의 circuit을
이야기할 때는 보통 비순환 circuit을 말하는 거예요.
순환 경로가 허용되지 않는 거죠.
더 정확히 말하면, 이 시리즈에서는
정보가 항상 어떤 circuit에서든 왼쪽에서 오른쪽으로 흐르도록 요구할 거예요.
원한다면, circuit을 시간이
왼쪽에서 오른쪽으로 흐르는 연산의 시퀀스를 설명하는 것으로 생각할 수 있어요.
여기 불리언 circuit의 예가 있어요. 와이어가 이진
값, 즉 0 또는 1을 전달하고,
gate는 불리언
논리 연산을 나타내요.
와이어는 선으로 표현되고, 여기 X와 Y라는
레이블이 붙은 두 개의 입력 비트가 있어요.
특정 입력 선택에 대해 circuit이
무엇을 하는지 알고 싶으면, 와이어의 값을
왼쪽에서 오른쪽으로 전파하면 돼요.
gate가 와이어에 의해 전달되는
값에 대해 수행하는 동작에 따라서요.
예를 들어, 위쪽 입력 와이어를
값 1로, 아래쪽 입력 와이어를 값 0으로
설정했을 때 어떤 일이 일어나는지 살펴볼 수 있어요.
이 두 입력 와이어는 여기 있는
이 두 점으로 연결되는데, 이것은 팬아웃 연산을 나타내요. 즉, 값이 복사되어서
여러 와이어를 따라
앞으로 전달될 수 있는 거예요.
이렇게 하면 이 두 와이어는
값 1을 가지게 되는데, 이것과 같고, 이 두 와이어는 값 0을 가지게 되는데,
이것과 같아요.
여기 NOT gate가 있는데, 논리 부정
기호로 표시되어 있어요. 그래서 나오는 값은 0이에요.
이것은 1의 논리 부정이에요. 마찬가지로
이 gate에서 나오는 값은 1인데, 이것은
0의 논리 부정이에요.
이 두 gate는 AND gate이고,
이 gate는 OR gate예요. 계속해서
값을 전파하면
circuit을 통해 gate를 적절히
평가하면, 이 와이어의 최종 값이 1이라는 것을 알 수 있어요.
그래서 전체 circuit은 그림이 보여주는 대로
구성된 일련의 연산을 설명하고, 결국
두 비트에서 한 비트로의 함수를 얻게 돼요.
이 특정 경우에요. 하지만 일반적으로는 임의의 수의
입력 및 출력 비트가 있을 수 있어요.
이 특정 circuit은 두 입력 비트의 배타적 OR을 계산해요. 그래서 출력이 1이 되려면
정확히
두 입력 비트 중 하나가 1이고 다른 하나가 0이어야 해요. 하지만 그건 별로
중요하지 않아요, 그냥 예시일 뿐이에요.
불리언 circuit에 대한 기본적인 사실은 임의의 수의 비트에서 임의의 수의 비트로의 어떤 함수든 계산할 수 있다는 거예요.
어떤 불리언 circuit으로든요. 다만 때때로
관심 있는 함수를 계산하려면
매우 큰 circuit이 필요할 수도 있어요.
circuit을 설명하는 데 사용되는
다른 스타일들도 있어요.
예를 들어, 이 그림은
이전에 봤던 것과 정확히 같은 circuit을 아마도 더 전형적인 스타일로 나타낸 거예요.
전기공학에서 다른 gate를 나타내는 모양에 대한 규약이 있는 스타일이에요.
우리는 이 특정 스타일을
사용하지 않을 거지만, Hadamard gate,
Controlled NOT gate 같은
Toffoli gate 등에 대한
우리만의 기호를 도입할 거예요.
여담으로, 여기서 circuit이라는
용어의 기원을 볼 수 있어요.
전기공학의 맥락에서는 전기가
circuit을 통해 순환하는 것을 생각하는 게 매우 자연스러워요.
하지만 이 시리즈에서는 전기가
circuit을 통해 이동하는 것이 아니라 정보가
circuit을 통해 이동하는 것을 이야기하고 있어요.
그리고 다시 한번, 우리에게 이것들은 항상 비순환적이고, 정보는
왼쪽에서 오른쪽으로 이동해요.
여기 산술 circuit이라고 불리는
다른 유형의 circuit의 다른 예가 있어요.
이번에는 와이어가 숫자를 저장하고 gate는
덧셈과 곱셈 같은 산술 연산을 나타내요.
여기 산술 circuit의
예를 볼 수 있어요.
이 수업을 위해 이것이 무엇을 하는지는
중요하지 않아요. 그냥 다양한 종류의 circuit
개념이 있다는 것을 전달하기 위한 예시일 뿐이에요.
무작위성을 포함하는 circuit도
생각할 수 있어요. 예를 들어 gate가
확률적 연산을 나타내는 경우인데,
원한다면 하루 종일 앉아서 circuit 개념에 기반한 새로운 계산 모델을 꿈꿀 수도 있을 거예요.
quantum circuit 모델에서는
와이어가 qubit을 나타내고, gate는 유니터리 연산과 측정 모두를 나타내요.
여기 quantum circuit의
매우 간단한 예가 있어요.
이 circuit에는 qubit이 하나만 있는데,
수평선으로 표현되고, 사각형으로
표시된 gate는
이 qubit에 수행되는 유니터리 연산을 나타내요.
이 특정 예에는
측정이 없어요.
qubit에 X 같은 이름을 주고 싶으면,
다이어그램에서 여기에 X를 넣어서 표시할 수 있어요. 이건 선택사항이에요.
조금 전의 불리언 circuit에서처럼, 이 circuit을
시간이 왼쪽에서 오른쪽으로 흐르는
일련의 연산으로 생각할 수 있어요.
X로 시작해서 첫 번째 gate인
Hadamard gate를 적용하고
그다음 S gate를 적용해요.
그다음 또 다른 Hadamard
gate, 그리고 마지막으로 T gate예요.
이 연산들은 수업 1의
마지막 부분에서 봤고, 여기서 행렬
설명을 볼 수 있어요.
이 네 가지 연산을 순서대로
수행하면, 즉 먼저 H, 그다음
S, 그다음 다시 H, 그리고 T를 수행하면,
결합된 연산은 여기 이 곱으로
주어지는데, 순서가 본질적으로
뒤집힌다는 것을 기억하세요.
수업 1에서 이야기한 것처럼요. 행렬 곱셈을 수행하면 여기 이 행렬을 얻어요.
그래서 circuit이 qubit X에
미치는 작용은 이 유니터리 행렬로 설명돼요.
때때로 quantum circuit 다이어그램에서
어떤 입력을 넣는지 명시적으로 표시하고 싶을 때가 있는데, 여기 보이는 것처럼 할 수 있어요.
이 경우에는 circuit에
Ket 0을 입력하고 있어요.
그건 꽤 일반적이에요. Ket 0을 qubit의
초기화된 상태로 사용하는 경우가 많지만, 꼭 그래야 하는 건 아니에요.
다른 상태에 circuit을
적용하는 것도 고려할 수 있어요.
원한다면 이렇게 얻게 되는
출력 상태도 표시할 수 있어요.
여기 또 다른 예가 있는데, 이번에는
다이어그램에서 볼 수 있듯이
X와 Y라는 두 개의 qubit이 있어요.
여기 Hadamard gate가 있는데, qubit Y에 적용되고, 그다음에 여기 이 기호로
표시된 gate가 있어요.
이것은 Controlled NOT gate예요. 이전 수업에서
Controlled NOT 연산에 대해 이야기했어요.
여기 이 다이어그램에서 제어 qubit은
Y인데, 작은 채워진 원으로 표시되어 있고,
대상 qubit은 X인데, 플러스 기호처럼 보이는 것이 있는 큰 원으로 표시되어 있어요.
배타적 OR의 기호처럼
보여서 의미가 통해요.
Y에 저장된 어떤 고전적 상태든
qubit X에 XOR된다고 상상할 수 있어요.
명확성을 위해, 여기 이 gate가
표준 기저 상태에 미치는 작용을 보여주는 다이어그램이 있어요.
A와 B가 이진 값이라고
가정해요.
다른 상태에 대한 작용은
항상 그렇듯이 선형성에 의해 결정돼요.
더 진행하기 전에, 이런 quantum circuit 다이어그램에서
qubit의 순서에 관해 따를 규약을 명시적으로 설명하는 것이 도움이 될 거예요.
이것과 같은 quantum circuit 다이어그램에서요.
규약은 quantum circuit 다이어그램에서
아래에서 위로의 순서가 튜플이나 텐서 곱에서의
왼쪽에서 오른쪽 순서와 동일하다는 거예요.
마치 튜플이나 텐서 곱에서처럼요.
이것은 시리즈에서 따를 규약이고
Qiskit에서도 사용되는 규약이에요.
이 특정 circuit의 경우, qubit 쌍
X, Y에 작용하는 것으로 생각하고 있어요.
X가 먼저 오는 이유는 아래에 있기 때문이고, Y가 마지막(이 경우 두 번째)으로 오는 이유는 위에 있기 때문이에요.
도움이 된다면 이것을 시각적으로 생각하는
방법은, 이 circuit을 시계 방향으로 회전시켜서
입력이 위에 오고
출력이 아래에 오도록 상상하면
qubit의 순서가 맞게 돼요.
이 순서 때문에 헷갈리는 경우가 있으니,
이 규약을 잘 기억해 두세요.
이 circuit이 설명하는 작용을 생각해 보면, 먼저
Y에 Hadamard gate가 적용되고
그다음 두 qubit에 Controlled NOT
gate가 적용되는데, Y가 제어이고
X가 대상이에요.
이 두 gate의 결합된 작용을 설명하는
유니터리 행렬을 적어보고 싶다면 그렇게 할 수 있어요.
먼저 Y에 대한 Hadamard gate를 고려해요.
Y에 Hadamard gate를 적용하고 X에는 아무것도 하지 않는데,
이것은 X에 항등 연산을 수행하는 것과 같아요.
그래서 두 qubit 전체에 대한 Hadamard gate의 작용은
항등 행렬과 Hadamard 연산을
나타내는 행렬의 텐서 곱으로 주어져요.
Y에 대한 Hadamard 연산이에요.
이렇게 생겼는데, X가 먼저 오고
Y가 두 번째라는 규약을 기억하세요.
그래서 항등 행렬과 H의 텐서 곱이에요.
그다음 Controlled NOT 연산을
적용하는데, 이 행렬 표현을 가지고 있고, 이것도 우리 규약과 일치해요.
두 번째 qubit Y가 제어이고 첫 번째 qubit X가 대상이에요.
영상을 멈추고 이것이 맞는지 확인하는 것을 두려워하지 마세요. 그리고 이 점에 대해 더 이상 상기시키지 않을게요.
이 영상들을 일시 정지하고, 원하는 만큼 여러 번 돌려보고,
원하면 재생 속도를 조절하고,
자신에게 가장 잘 맞는 방식으로 사용할 수 있어요.
어쨌든, 두 연산을 합성하면
결합된 작용은 여기 이 곱으로 설명돼요.
이 두 행렬이 이 순서로 곱해지는 이유는
Hadamard가 먼저 수행되고 Controlled NOT이
두 번째로 수행되기 때문이에요.
다시 한번, 이것은 수업 1에서 이야기한 것과
일치하는데, 순서가 본질적으로
뒤집힌다는 거예요.
행렬 곱셈을 수행하면 여기 이 행렬을 얻어요.
그리고 이 행렬에서 circuit이 표준 기저 상태에
대해 무엇을 하는지 읽어낼 수 있어요.
입력 0, 0에 대해 circuit을 실행하면, 즉 첫 번째 qubit이 Ket 0이고 두 번째 qubit이 Ket 0이면,
결과는 Phi+ Bell 상태인데,
행렬의 첫 번째 열에서 볼 수 있어요.
0, 1을 넣으면 Phi- 상태를 얻고, 1, 0은 Psi+ 상태를 줘요.
그리고 1, 1은 Psi-가 아니라 -1 곱하기 Psi-를 줘요.
마이너스 부호는 여기서 별로
중요하지 않아요. 이것을 없애고 싶으면
두 qubit에 스왑 연산을 수행하면 되고
처음 세 표준 기저 상태에 일어난 일을
망치지 않을 거예요.
하지만 이 예시에서는
정말 중요하지 않아요.
요약하면, circuit은 표준 기저 상태에 대해 여기 이런 작용을 해요.
특정 circuit이 무엇을 하는지
생각할 때, 행렬로 변환해서
곱할 필요는 없어요.
circuit이 특정 상태에 미치는 작용을
추적할 수도 있고, 많은 경우에 이것이
선호되는 옵션이 될 거예요.
이 예에서는 gate의 작용을 살펴봄으로써
circuit이 0, 0 상태에 무엇을 하는지 볼 수 있어요.
초기 상태는 Bell 상태와의
혼동을 피하기 위해 Pi 제로라고 이름 붙였는데, 0, 0이에요.
Hadamard gate를 적용하면 0+라는 상태를 얻는데, 이렇게 전개할 수 있어요.
그다음 Controlled NOT 연산이 이 상태를 Phi+ 상태로 만드는데, Controlled NOT이 표준 기저 상태에
미치는 작용을 생각하면 알 수 있어요.
나머지 세 표준 기저 상태나 다른
어떤 상태에 대해서도 같은 방식으로 할 수 있어요.
quantum circuit 다이어그램에 고전적 비트도 포함할 수 있어요.
이 다이어그램에서 보이는 것처럼
이중선으로 표시돼요.
즉, A와 B는 고전적 비트이고 X와 Y는 qubit이에요.
이전 예와 같은 두 유니터리 gate가 있고, 여기 이 기호들은 표준 기저 측정을 나타내요.
구체적으로, 두 유니터리 연산이 수행된 후에
Y에 대해 표준 기저 측정이 수행돼요.
그리고 결과가 고전적 비트 B에
덮어씌워지고, 마찬가지로 X가 측정되고 그 결과가 비트 A에 기록돼요.
여기서 qubit X와 Y가 측정된 후에도 계속되는 것을 볼 수 있어요.
하지만 측정된 후의 qubit에 대해
그다지 신경 쓰지 않는 경우가 꽤 흔해요.
때때로 우리가 관심 있는 것은
측정 결과뿐이에요. 그런 경우에는 여기 보이는
약식 스타일을 사용할 수 있어요.
측정에 qubit이 들어가고 고전적 비트가 나오는 형태예요.
여기서의 이해는 qubit이 측정되면
그냥 버려지거나 무시되고 고전적 측정
결과가 앞으로 전달된다는 거예요.
시리즈가 계속되면서, quantum circuit의
많은 예를 보게 될 건데, 방금 본
매우 간단한 예보다 훨씬 더 복잡할 거예요.
앞서 언급했듯이, 다른 gate에는
다른 기호가 사용돼요.
단일 qubit gate는 보통 어떤 연산인지
나타내는 글자가 적힌 사각형으로 표시돼요.
때때로 이런 다양한 gate들이
다른 의미를 나타내기 위해 색으로 구분되기도 하지만,
지금은 그것을 무시할게요.
이미 Controlled NOT gate를
봤어요.
스왑 gate는 여기 보이는 것처럼
표시되고, Toffoli gate와 Fredkin gate는
여기 보이는 것처럼 표시돼요.
Toffoli gate는 제어된 Controlled NOT gate이고 Fredkin gate는
제어된 스왑 gate라는 것을 기억하세요.
그래서 이 기호들은 제어 qubit이
gate를 제어하는 선으로 연결된 채워진 원으로
표시된다는 아이디어와 일치해요.
일반적으로, 제어 qubit이
꼭 위에 있을 필요는 없고, 이 gate들이
인접한 qubit에만 작용할 필요도 없어요. 즉, 이 gate들이
작용하지 않는 다른 qubit들을 가로질러
늘어날 수 있고, 이후 수업에서 그런 경우를 볼 거예요.
quantum circuit 모델을 사용할 때 자주 하는 한 가지 더는 임의의 유니터리 연산을
임의의 수의 qubit에 대해
여기 보이는 것처럼 단일 gate로 보는 거예요.
유니터리 연산이 무엇이든 그에 해당하는
레이블이 있는 직사각형을 그리면 돼요.
이 경우에는 어떤
유니터리 연산 U예요.
물론 이 다이어그램에서 U가 무엇인지는
알 수 없고, U가 어떻게든 정의되어 있다고 가정하거나
어떤 임의의
유니터리 연산 U를 고려하고 있다고 생각해야 해요. 예를 들어 명확성을 위해
U를 서브루틴으로 생각하고 싶을 수도 있어요.
여기 보이는 이 표기법도
사용하는데, 제어 U 연산을 위한 것이에요.
이전처럼 제어 qubit은 채워진 원으로 표시돼요.
quantum circuit 모델에 대한 간단한 소개였어요.
앞서 말했듯이, quantum circuit의 더 많은 예를
시리즈를 계속하면서 보게 될 거예요.
수업의 다음 부분에서는 내적,
직교정규성, 그리고 사영에 대해 살펴볼 건데, 이것들은 매우 중요한 개념이에요.
양자 정보와 계산에서요.
내적부터 시작할게요.
디랙 표기법을 사용할 때 Ket은
열 벡터이고 Bra는 행 벡터라는 것을 기억하세요.
구체적으로, 주어진 열 벡터에 대응하는
Bra 벡터는 그 열 벡터의 켤레 전치예요.
여기 이 벡터에 대해, 벡터를 행렬처럼
전치해서 대응하는 Bra 벡터를 구하는데,
이것은 옆으로 눕히고 각 성분의 복소 켤레를 취하는 것이에요.
이제, 이렇게 같은 수의 성분을 가진 두 Ket이 있다고 가정해요.
여기 이 브래킷을 형성하면, 이것은 단순히
Bra와 Ket의 곱을 행렬처럼 취하는 것인데,
여기 보이는 이 식을 얻게 돼요.
이것은 스칼라, 즉 복소수예요.
이 값을 이 두 벡터의
내적이라고 불러요.
벡터가 표준 기저 벡터의
선형 결합으로 표현된 형태의 벡터에 대해서도
내적을 생각할 수 있어요.
표준 기저 벡터들의 선형 결합이에요.
이 벡터들의 내적은 이전과 같은 방식으로 정의돼요.
Bra Psi 곱하기 Ket Phi인데, 이렇게
곱으로 표현할 수 있어요.
계산하고 정리하면, 내적에 대한 여기 이 식이 남는데, 이전에 있던 것과 유사해요.
다만 이번에는 고전적 상태 집합의
원소에 대해 합을 취하는데, 이 경우에는 시그마예요.
여기 내적이 어떻게 작동하는지에 대한
기하학적 그림을 보여주는 예가 있어요.
qubit에 해당하는 2차원 공간에
원을 그렸는데, 실수 성분을 가진
벡터로 제한하는 한
이 평면 위의 점으로 그릴 수 있어요.
Phi를 여기 이 벡터로
정해볼게요.
유클리드 노름을 계산해 보면 단위 벡터인 것을 알 수 있고,
이 원이 나타내는 것이 바로 그거예요.
실수 성분을 가진 모든
단위 벡터들이에요.
Psi도 여기 이 벡터로 정해볼게요.
이것도 역시 단위 벡터예요.
사실 마이너스 상태인데, 여기서는 그냥 Psi라고 부르고 있어요.
이 두 벡터의 내적을 계산하면,
1 빼기 루트 3을 2 곱하기 루트 2로 나눈 값을 얻어요.
이것은 대략 -1/4이에요.
이 내적의 값은 두 벡터 사이 각도의
코사인과 같은데, 그림에서 볼 수 있어요.
이것은 단위 벡터에 대해 일반적으로
성립하는 것이에요. 두 단위 벡터가 있고 둘 다 실수 성분을 가지면,
두 벡터 사이의 내적은 두 벡터 사이
각도의 코사인과 같아요.
특히, 이 예에서처럼 내적이 0이면,
Psi를 여기 이 상태로 바꾼 경우인데,
두 벡터는 서로
90도 각도에 있어야 해요.
이 모든 것은 어떤 차원의 벡터에도
일반화되는데, 성분이 실수이기만 하면 돼요.
2차원 벡터에만 해당하는 것이 아니에요.
복소수 성분이 있으면 이 그림은
더 이상 맞지 않지만, 그럼에도 불구하고
내적은 보게 되듯이 매우 유용해요.
내적은 매우 중요한 성질들이 있고
지금부터 그 성질 몇 가지를 살펴볼 거예요.
첫 번째는 내적과
유클리드 노름 사이의 관계예요.
어떤 벡터와 자기 자신의 내적을 취하면
유클리드 노름의 제곱을 얻어요.
그래서 벡터의 유클리드 노름은 그 벡터와
자기 자신의 내적의 제곱근과 같다고
말할 수도 있어요.
이것은 우연이 아니에요, 근본적인
관계예요. 여기서 내적의 정의에
복소 켤레가 없었다면
이 공식이 더 이상 성립하지 않을 거고,
유클리드 노름과의 이런 근본적인 관계를 가진
유용한 개념이 되지 못했을 거예요.
유클리드 노름과의 이런 근본적인 관계 말이에요.
다음으로, 내적은 켤레 대칭이에요.
이것은 두 인수의 순서를 바꾸면
내적의 값이 켤레가 된다는 뜻이에요.
이것은 여기 이 등식으로 표현되고,
이 두 식에 대해 왜 그런지 보는 것은 꽤 직관적이에요.
두 가능한 순서에서의 두 벡터의 내적이에요.
내적은 두 번째 인수에 대해 선형이에요.
구체적으로, 벡터 Phi를 두 벡터의
선형 결합으로 정의하면,
Phi 1과 Phi 2의 선형 결합으로 정의하면,
어떤 벡터 Psi와 Phi의 내적은
두 내적의 같은 선형 결합이에요.
이것은 행렬 곱셈이 선형이라는
사실에서 바로 따라와요.
그리고 내적은 첫 번째 인수에 대해
켤레 선형이기도 한데, 여기서 볼 수 있어요.
Psi가 벡터들의 이런
선형 결합이면, Psi와 Phi의
내적을 취할 때,
Bra Psi는 여기 보이는 이 벡터가 되는데,
베타 1과 베타 2의 복소 켤레를 취한 거예요.
그래서 이것이 결과이고, 이것이
켤레 선형성이 의미하는 거예요.
내적의 마지막으로 언급하고 싶은 성질은
엄청나게 유용한 코시-슈바르츠 부등식이에요.
어떤 두 벡터 Psi와 Phi에 대해, 내적의 절댓값은 두 벡터의
유클리드 노름의 곱보다
결코 클 수 없어요. 게다가 부등식의 양변이
같을 수 있는 유일한 경우는 두 벡터가 선형 종속인 경우인데,
이것은 하나가 다른 하나의 스칼라 배와 같다는 뜻이에요.
이것은 사실 모든 수학에서
가장 널리 사용되는 부등식 중 하나이고
양자 정보를 다룰 때 계속해서 사용해요.
그래서 알아두면 매우 좋아요.
다음으로, 내적과 관련된
직교성과 직교정규성의 개념에 대해 이야기할 거예요.
구체적으로, 벡터의 내적이
0과 같은 경우에 대해서요.
정확히 말하면, 두 벡터 Psi와 Phi가
있을 때, 내적이
0과 같으면 직교한다고 말해요.
직교하는 벡터를 직관적으로 생각하는 방법은
서로 직각에 있다는 것이에요.
또는 서로
수직이라고도 할 수 있어요.
사람들은 때때로 직교라는 용어를 서로 전혀
관련이 없는 것들을 지칭할 때 사용해요.
어떤 이슈가 다른 이슈와 직교한다고 말하는 것처럼요.
하지만 그것은 분명히 꽤 비공식적이고
수학적 의미에서 실제로 의미가 있는 건 아니에요. 하지만 직교하는 벡터가 가리키는 방향을 생각하면 연결이 명확해요.
반대 방향이 아니라, 예를 들어 북쪽 대 서쪽처럼 완전히 다른 방향을 가리키는 거예요.
벡터의 집합이 있을 때, 그 집합에서 선택한 어떤 두 서로 다른 벡터가
반드시 서로 직교하면 그 집합을 직교 집합이라고 해요.
이것은 여기 보이는 것처럼 표현할 수 있어요.
직교정규 집합은 단순히
단위 벡터들의 직교 집합이에요.
직교 집합의 벡터들은 반드시
단위 벡터일 필요는 없고, 사실 영 벡터가
직교 집합의 원소일 수도 있지만, 직교정규 집합에서는 모든 벡터가 단위 벡터여야 해요.
집합이 직교 집합이라는
요구 사항에 더해서요.
내적과 유클리드 노름 사이의 관계를
알고 있으니, 이 조건을 여기 보이는 것처럼
꽤 간결하게 표현할 수 있어요.
여기 보이는 것처럼요.
그리고 마지막으로, 직교정규 기저는 단순히
우리가 다루는 벡터 공간에 대한
기저를 형성하는 직교정규 집합이에요.
예를 들어, 어떤 고전적 상태 집합
시그마를 취하고 모든 표준 기저 벡터의
집합을 생각하면,
이것이 직교정규 집합이고, 사실 이 고전적 상태 집합 시그마에 해당하는 성분을 가진 모든 벡터의 공간에 대한 직교정규 기저라는 것을 알 수 있어요.
이것들은 모두 단위 벡터이고
쌍으로 직교하니까 직교정규 집합이에요.
기저이기도 하니까 직교정규 기저예요.
직교정규 집합은 항상 선형 독립이에요.
그래서 직교정규 집합이 있으면
항상 어떤 부분 공간에 대한 직교정규 기저가 될 거예요.
하지만 이 경우에는 우리가 작업하는 전체 공간에 대한 기저예요.
또 다른 예는 Ket+와
Ket-를 포함하는 집합이에요.
이 두 벡터는 직교하고, 내적이 0이에요.
둘 다 단위 벡터이고 단일 qubit에 해당하는
2차원 벡터 공간을 생성하니까,
이 공간에 대한 직교정규 기저를 형성해요.
또 다른 예는 Bell 기저인데, 이것은
두 qubit에 해당하는 모든 4차원 벡터의
공간에 대한 직교정규 기저예요.
반면에, Ket 0과 Ket+를 포함하는
집합은 직교 집합이 아닌데, 이 벡터들 사이의 내적이 0이 아니기 때문이에요.
둘 다 단위 벡터이고 qubit에 해당하는 벡터 공간의 기저이지만, 직교성이 없어요.
여기 가끔 활용할 직교정규 집합에 대한 편리한 사실이 있어요.
어떤 직교정규 벡터 집합이 있다고 가정해요.
구체적으로, 이 집합에 M개의 벡터가 있다고 합시다.
Psi 1부터 Psi M까지인데,
이 벡터들이 어떤 N차원 벡터 공간에서 가져온 것이라고 가정해요.
다시 말해, 각 벡터가 M개의 성분을 가지고 있어요.
이미 언급했듯이, 직교정규 집합은 항상
선형 독립이니까, M이 N보다 클 수 없어요.
하지만 M이 N보다 작을 수는 있고,
그것이 우리가 관심 있는 경우예요.
이 사실이 말하는 것은 M이 N보다 작으면,
우리 공간에 대한 직교정규 기저를 얻기 위해
시작한 집합에 추가적인 벡터를
항상 추가할 수 있다는 거예요.
정확히 말하면, 벡터 Psi M+1부터 Psi N까지가
반드시 존재해서 전체 모음이
직교정규 기저를 형성해요.
그러니까 말하자면, 직교정규 기저로 확장할 수 없는
직교정규 벡터 집합을 선택해서
궁지에 몰리는 일은 절대 없어요.
때로는 시작한 집합을 보고 직교정규 기저로 확장하는 방법을 알아낼 수 있지만, 항상 작동하는 대안은
그람-슈미트 직교정규화 과정이라는
절차를 사용해서 이런 벡터들을 구성하는 거예요.
이 수업이나 이 시리즈에서 그 절차를
설명하지는 않을 건데, 세부 사항이 우리에게
별로 중요하지 않기 때문이에요. 하지만 궁금하시면 찾아볼 수 있어요.
이것은 컴퓨터가 수행할 수 있는 것이에요.
그래서 창의성은 필요 없고,
그냥 기계적인 절차예요.
이것이 이렇게 편리한 사실인 이유 중 하나는
직교정규 기저와 유니터리 행렬 사이에
존재하는 밀접한 관계와 관련이 있어요.
특히, 어떤 정방 행렬 U에 대해, 여기 보이는 세 가지 조건은 항상 동치예요.
즉, 모두 참이거나
모두 거짓이에요.
첫 번째 조건은 U가 유니터리 행렬이라는 것인데,
이것은 U 대거 곱하기 U와 U 곱하기 U 대거가 모두
항등 행렬과 같다는 뜻이에요.
두 번째 조건은 U의 행들이
직교정규 기저를 형성한다는 것이고,
세 번째 조건은 U의 열들이
직교정규 기저를 형성한다는 거예요.
이 동치가 왜 성립하는지
보는 것은 사실 그렇게 어렵지 않아요.
간단하게 하기 위해, 여기 보이는
3x3 행렬 U를 살펴봅시다.
성분은 원하는 어떤 복소수든 될 수 있어요.
여기 왼쪽에 편의를 위해
U의 켤레 전치를 적어놨어요.
U의 열로부터 세 벡터를 만들면,
여기서 Psi 1, Psi 2, Psi 3이라고
이름 붙였는데, U 대거와 U의 곱을 취하면,
곱의 각 성분이 여기 이 패턴에서
보이는 것처럼 벡터들의 내적으로 주어진다는 것을 확인할 수 있어요.
U가 유니터리라는 조건을 생각하면, 이것은 이 행렬이 항등 행렬과 같다는 것과 동치인데,
세 벡터가 직교정규 집합을 형성하는 것과
동치라는 것을 알 수 있어요.
대각선 성분이 모두 1이어야 하니까
반드시 단위 벡터이고, 비대각선 성분이
0이어야 하니까
벡터들의 직교 집합이에요.
그래서 U가 유니터리인 것은 열들이 직교정규 집합을 형성하는 것과 동치예요.
그리고 집합의 벡터 수가, 이 경우 3개인데, 공간의 차원과 일치하니까 기저가 되어야 해요.
열 대신 행에 대해서도 비슷한 논증을 따를 수 있는데, U가 유니터리인 것은
행들이 직교정규 기저를 형성하는 것과 동치라는 결론을 내릴 수 있어요.
복소 켤레가 올바르게 작동하도록 조정이 필요하기 때문에 그렇게 깔끔하게 되지는 않지만, 아이디어는 같아요.
대안적인 방법은 행렬이 유니터리인 것과 전치가 유니터리인 것이 동치임을 증명하는 것인데, 이것은 꽤 직관적이에요.
여기서 전치라고 한 것이 맞아요, 켤레 전치가 아니라요.
유니터리 행렬의 정의에서 어떤
유니터리 행렬의 켤레 전치가 유니터리라는 것은 매우 자명해요.
하지만 어떤 유니터리 행렬의 전치도 유니터리라는 것 역시 사실이에요.
어쨌든, 정방 행렬 U에 대한 이 세 조건의
동치를 가지고 있고, 이 동치를
직교정규 집합을 확장해서 직교정규 기저를 형성하는 사실과 결합해서
유니터리 행렬을 만들 수 있어요.
흥미로운 일을 하거나 만나게 되는
다양한 필요를 충족하는 유니터리 행렬을요.
구체적으로, M개의 벡터로 된
직교정규 집합이 있을 때마다, 항상 유니터리 행렬 U가 존재해서
처음 M개의 열이 그 직교정규 집합의 벡터가 돼요.
나머지 열은 열들이 직교정규 기저를
형성하도록 선택해서 유니터리 행렬을
얻을 수 있도록 항상 채울 수 있어요.
직교정규 기저를 형성하도록요.
이것은 우리가 가지고 있으면 꽤 편리한 사실이 될 거예요.
이 수업의 이 부분에서 다룰
마지막 주제는 사영의 개념이에요.
정방 행렬 Pi가 여기 나열된
두 가지 성질이 모두 참이면
사영 또는 사영 행렬이라고 해요.
참고로 이것은 대문자 Pi예요. 사영을 나타내는 데 사용되는 문자로 꽤 전형적인 선택이에요.
행렬 같은 객체에 이런 전형적인 이름을 붙이는 경우가 많은데, 인식하기 쉽고 구분하기 쉽게 하려고요.
하지만 원하는 어떤 이름이든 사용할 수 있어요. 어쨌든, 첫 번째 조건은 Pi가 자신의 켤레 전치와 같다는 거예요.
일반적으로, 행렬이 자신의 켤레 전치와 같으면
에르미트 행렬이라고 해요.
그래서 첫 번째 조건은 Pi가 에르미트하다고도 말할 수 있어요.
두 번째 조건은 Pi를 제곱하면,
즉 Pi를 자기 자신에 곱하면
다시 Pi를 얻는다는 거예요.
Pi를 제곱해도 아무 변화가 없는 거예요.
직관적으로 말해서 사영의 아이디어는
이미지를 스크린에 투영하거나 선에
수선을 내리는 것과 비슷한 거예요.
벡터에 사영을 곱하면,
어떤 의미에서
일부분은 그대로 두고
나머지는 0으로 만드는 거예요.
사영을 두 번째로 적용하면 아무것도
하지 않는데, 사영이 0으로 만드는 부분을
이미 0으로 만들었기 때문이에요.
사영의 예로, 어떤 단위 벡터
Psi에 대한 여기 이 행렬이 있어요.
필요한 조건을 하나씩
만족하는지 확인할 수 있어요.
첫 번째에 대해, 켤레 전치를 계산하는데
이것은 곱의 켤레 전치예요.
그래서 곱의 켤레 전치에 대한 이 공식을
사용해서 도움을 받을 수 있어요.
얻게 되는 것은 켤레 전치들의 곱인데,
순서가 뒤집혀요.
전치 부분 때문에
그렇게 되는 거예요.
이 공식을 적용하면 여기 이 등식을 얻고,
정리하면 원래 행렬을 다시 얻을 수 있어요.
참고로, Psi가 단위 벡터라는
사실을 사용하지 않았어요.
그래서 사실, 이 행렬은 단위 벡터뿐만 아니라
어떤 벡터 Psi에 대해서도 에르미트해요.
두 번째에 대해, Pi를 제곱하면 여기 이 식을
얻는데, 이것은 원래 행렬과 같아요. 이번에는
Psi가 단위 벡터이기 때문에, 여기 이 내적이
1과 같고 Psi가 단위 벡터라는 가정이
들어오는 부분이에요.
이 예를 일반화해서 직교정규 집합으로 시작할 수 있어요.
개별 벡터에 해당하는 사영들을 합한 여기 이 행렬을 형성하면 사영을 얻어요.
화면에서 그것을 보여주는 계산을 볼 수 있고, 원하시면 살펴보세요.
첫 번째 예와 비슷한 맥락에서,
집합의 직교정규성이 사용되는 것은
두 번째 조건에서예요.
이 사영이 벡터에 곱해졌을 때 하는 일은
그 벡터를 이 벡터 집합이 생성하는
부분 공간에 사영하는 거예요.
추상적으로는 그 부분 공간에 수선을
내리는 것과 같고, 그 부분 공간 안에 들어가면
사영이 아무것도 하지 않아요.
이런 행렬들이 사영의 예인데,
이제 사실 모든 가능성을 다 살펴본 거예요.
모든 사영 행렬은 어떤 직교정규 집합의 선택에 대해 이런 형태를 취해요.
영 행렬도 사영이니까, 모든 사영을 얻고 싶으면 그것도 포함해야 해요.
명확히 하자면, M이 0일 수 있는 가능성을 허용하고 있고, 그러면 빈 합을 얻는데,
이것은 영 행렬로 해석할 수 있어요.
이제 사영의 개념이 있으니, 사영 측정이라고 알려진
더 일반적인 유형의 양자 측정을 정의할 수 있어요.
이것이 가장 일반적인 측정 개념은 아니지만,
표준 기저 측정보다 훨씬 더 일반적이고
양자 정보의 설명에 이것을
포함하는 것이 매우 도움이 될 거예요.
사영 측정은 여기 보이는 조건을 만족하는
사영의 집합으로 정의되는데, 이 조건은
사영들의 합이 항등 행렬이 되는 거예요.
여기서 M은 원하는 어떤 양의 정수든 될 수 있는데,
이것들이 모두 사영이고 이 조건이 참이면
그 모음이 사영 측정을
정의해요.
이런 모음으로 설명되는 측정은
어떤 양자 상태 Psi를 측정할 때 다음과 같이 작동해요.
먼저 1과 M 사이의 결과를 얻는데,
M은 사영의 수예요.
각 가능한 결과 K에 대해, 그 결과를 얻을 확률은
Psi에 K번째 사영인
Pi K를 곱한 벡터의 유클리드 노름의 제곱이에요.
이 양을 여기 보이는 것처럼
쓸 수도 있어요.
이 등식은 유클리드 노름과 내적 사이의 관계와
Pi K가 사영이라는 사실에서 나와요.
두 번째 형태에서, 이 사영들에 대한 조건과 함께, 선형성에 의해 확률의 합이 항상 1이 된다는 것을 바로 알 수 있어요.
Psi가 단위 벡터여야 한다는 것을
기억하세요.
그리고 두 번째로, 결과 K를 얻었다고 가정하면,
시스템의 상태가 사영에 의해 얻은 벡터를
정규화해서 얻는 양자 상태로 붕괴해요.
곧 몇 가지 예를 살펴볼 건데,
그전에 실제로는
가능한 결과들을 1부터 M까지
번호 매길 필요가 없다는 것을 언급할게요. 결과에 원하는 어떤 이름이나 기호를 선택할 수 있어요.
특히, 어떤 집합 감마의 기호로
레이블된 사영의 모음이 있고,
이전과 같은 조건, 즉 합이
항등 행렬이 되는 조건을 만족하면,
사영 측정을 가지게 돼요.
이전과 정확히 같은 방식으로
작동하는 거예요.
여기서 유일한 차이는 측정 결과가
1부터 M까지의 정수가 아니라
이 집합 감마의 원소가 될 수 있다는 거예요.
사영 측정의 첫 번째 예로,
표준 기저 측정이 사영 측정이라는 것을 관찰해 봅시다.
이 경우 측정의 결과 집합은
측정되는 시스템의 고전적 상태 집합과 같아요.
측정을 설명하는 사영의 집합은
여기 이 모음인데, 시그마가
시스템의 고전적 상태 집합이라고 가정해요.
이것들은 모두 사영이고 합하면
항등 행렬이 되니까 유효한 사영 측정이에요.
이것이 좀 더 자세히 어떻게 작동하는지
보기 위해, 여기 보이는 형태로 적힌
임의의 상태가 있다고 가정합시다.
조금 전의 설명에 따르면, 측정이
결과 A를 산출할 확률은 여기 이 값인데,
이것은 벡터 Psi의 대응하는 성분의
절댓값 제곱과 같고,
이것은 우리가 기대하는 바예요.
결과가 A라는 조건 하에, 시스템의 상태는
조금 전의 설명에 따르면 이렇게 돼요.
정리하면, 기대하는 상태인
Ket A를 정확히 얻지는 못해요.
대신 Ket A에 스칼라를
곱한 것을 얻는데, 구체적으로 이것은
절댓값이 1인 스칼라예요.
단위원 위의
복소수인 거예요.
이것을 글로벌 위상이라고 부르고 곧 글로벌 위상에 대해 논의할 건데, 지금은 간단히 말해서
이 상태는 Ket A와 동치예요.
이 글로벌 위상은 실제로 아무런
의미가 없고, 글로벌 위상에 대한
논의에서 왜 그런지 볼 거예요.
글로벌 위상의 이 문제를 빼면, 곧 이야기할 건데, 표준 기저 측정이
사실 사영 측정이라는 것을 알 수 있어요. 이전 예의 확장인
또 다른 예로,
이전 수업에서 이야기한 것처럼 시스템 X에 표준 기저
측정을 수행하고 시스템 Y에는 아무것도 하지 않으면,
시스템 X, Y를 측정하는 것과
완전히 동치예요.
여기 이 사영 측정으로요.
X의 고전적 상태에 대응하는 이 사영들이 있고, Y에 대한 항등 행렬과 텐서 곱을 해요.
이것은 Y에 아무것도 하지 않는다는
사실을 반영해요.
사영 측정이 일반적으로 어떻게
작동하는지에 대한 설명이 이 예에서 어떻게 되는지 알려주고,
이것이 사실
이전 수업에서 논의한 것과 완전히 동치인지 확인하는 것은 여러분에게 맡길게요.
이것은 매우 좋은데, 이 사영 측정 설명이
어떤 의미에서 더 깔끔하고, 이것이 더 일반적인
그림에 들어맞는 것을 볼 수 있기 때문이에요.
사영 측정의 또 하나의
예가 있어요.
이것은 두 qubit에 대한 측정이에요.
이 측정에서는 두 개의 사영이 있고,
따라서 0과 1이라는 두 가지 가능한 결과가 있어요.
사영은 여기 보이는 것처럼
Bell 상태를 사용해서 정의돼요.
첫 번째 사영은 세 대칭 Bell 상태가
생성하는 공간에 대한 것이고,
두 번째 사영은
반대칭인 Psi- 상태가 생성하는
1차원 공간에 대한 것이에요. 다시 말해서
두 qubit에 스왑 연산을 수행하면
-1이 곱해지는 것이에요.
시리즈 후반에 왜 이것이 흥미로운 측정인지 볼 거예요.
지금은 이전에 봤던 것,
즉 Bell 기저와 연결되는
그냥 예시일 뿐이에요.
사영 측정에 대한 마지막 참고 사항은 사영 측정이 있으면, 항상 그 측정을
유니터리 연산과 표준 기저 측정을
사용해서 구현할 수 있다는 거예요.
예를 들어, 이 특정 측정의 경우,
여기 보이는 것처럼 측정을 구현하는
quantum circuit을 만들 수 있어요.
위의 두 qubit이 이 사영 측정으로
측정하려는 qubit이라고 상상하고,
할 수 있는 것은 새로운 qubit을 도입하는 거예요.
0 상태로 초기화되어 시작하는 거예요.
Hadamard gate를 수행하고 Fredkin gate를 수행하고
또 다른 Hadamard gate를 수행해요.
이 아래 qubit을 표준 기저 측정으로 측정하면, 효과는 위의 두 qubit을
이 예의 사영 측정으로 측정한 것과
정확히 같아요.
두 결과에 대해 정확히 같은 확률을 얻고, 측정이 위의 두 qubit에 미치는 효과도 같아요.
이것은 전혀 자명하지 않아요. 이를 보려면 분석이 필요하고, 그 분석은 여기에 나와 있지 않아요.
이미 제안했듯이, 이 특정 측정을
이후 수업에서 더 자세히 살펴볼 거고,
지금은 그냥 예시일 뿐이에요.
알아가야 할 중요한 점은 이런 것이
어떤 사영 측정에 대해서든 항상 가능하다는 거예요. 그래서 사영 측정을 도입함으로써
추가적인 능력을 실제로 얻지는 못하지만,
매우 유용한 개념이고 시리즈를 계속하면서
사영 측정에 대해 자주 이야기할 거예요.
이 수업의 마지막 부분은 양자 정보의
몇 가지 중요한 한계와
quantum circuit으로 할 수 있는 것들에 대한 거예요.
첫 번째 한계는, 아마 한계라기보다는 축퇴에 가까운 것인데, 글로벌 위상의 문제에 관한 거예요.
조금 전에 언급했어요. 여기 글로벌 위상이 무엇을 의미하는지에 대한 정의가 있어요.
두 양자 상태 벡터 Psi와 Phi가 있을 때,
하나가 다른 하나에 어떤 복소수 알파를 곱한 것과 같으면,
이 두 상태가 글로벌 위상만큼
다르다고, 또는 글로벌 위상까지 동치라고 말해요.
양자 상태 벡터의 유클리드 노름이 1이기 때문에, 이 등식이 성립할 수 있는 유일한 방법은
이 복소수의 절댓값이 1인 경우예요.
그래서 알파는 단위원 위에 있어야 해요.
글로벌 위상만큼 다른 이런 두 양자 상태가 있고
상태 Phi를 측정한다고 가정해 봅시다.
표준 기저 측정으로요.
어떤 결과 A를 얻을 확률은 여기 이 식으로 주어지는데,
Phi 대신 알파 곱하기 Psi를 대입하면,
같다고 가정하고 있으니까 대입할 수 있고,
이 확률을 얻어요.
알파가 복소 단위원 위에 있다는 사실을 사용해서
정리하면 이 확률을 얻어요.
이것이 Phi를 측정해서 결과 A를 얻을 확률이라는 것을 기억하세요. 하지만 이제 이것이
Psi를 측정해서 결과 A를 얻을 확률과
정확히 같다는 것을 알 수 있어요.
그래서 두 상태에 대해 다른 결과의 확률에
전혀 차이가 없어요.
비슷한 논증을 통해 더 일반적으로 어떤 사영 측정에 대해서도 확률이 다시 동일하다는 것을 알 수 있어요.
그래서 측정으로는 글로벌 위상만큼 다른
두 상태의 차이를 구별할 수 없어요.
통계적인 의미에서도요.
마지막으로, 상태 Phi에 어떤
유니터리 연산을 적용하면, 다시 대입을 통해, 얻게 되는 것은 정확히 같은 복소수 알파에
같은 유니터리 연산을 상태 Psi에 적용해서
얻게 되는 것을 곱한 것이에요.
그래서 두 상태는 여전히
글로벌 위상만큼 달라요.
요점은 두 상태가 완전히 구별 불가능하다는 거예요.
그래서 실제로 둘 사이에 차이가 전혀 없어요.
유니터리 연산과 측정을 수행해서
알아낼 수 있는 것의 관점에서요. 이런 이유로
이 두 상태를 동치로 간주하거나,
원한다면, 이것들이 같은 양자 상태의
가능하게는 다른 두 벡터
표현이라고 볼 수 있어요.
논의 시작 때 말했듯이,
이것은 기본적으로 양자 상태가 양자 상태
벡터로 설명되는 방식의 축퇴예요.
어쨌든, 이것이 의미하는 것은 글로벌 위상을
그냥 무시할 수 있다는 거예요. 표준 기저 측정을
사영 측정으로 설명할 때 사실상 그렇게 했던 것처럼요. 참고로, 이 축퇴는 양자 정보의 단순화된 설명에서만 일어나요.
시리즈의 세 번째 단원에서 하게 될 것처럼
밀도 행렬을 사용해서 양자 상태를 설명하면,
각 양자 상태에 대해 유일한 행렬 표현을 가지게 돼요.
양자 정보의 일반적인 설명에서는
글로벌 위상의 문제가 단순히 발생하지 않아요.
이것은 양자 정보의 일반적인 설명의
또 하나의 매력적인 측면인데, 계속
암시하고 있지만, 어쨌든 글로벌 위상은
우리를 괴롭히지 않을 거예요.
그것을 무시할 자유를
행사할 수 있으니까요.
글로벌 위상의 개념이 명확한지
확인하기 위한 매우 간단한 예가 있어요.
마이너스 상태와 -1 곱하기 마이너스 상태가 있으면,
이 두 상태는 글로벌 위상만큼 다르고,
특히 알파는 -1이에요.
반면에, 플러스 상태와 마이너스 상태가 있으면,
글로벌 위상만큼 다른 두 상태가 아니에요.
이것들은 직교 벡터이니까 선형 독립이에요.
두 양자 상태 벡터가 글로벌 위상만큼 다르다는 것은
벡터들이 선형 종속이라는 것과 동치예요.
그래서 확실히 이 벡터들은
글로벌 위상만큼 다르지 않아요.
유일한 차이가 이 플러스 부호가 이 마이너스 부호로
바뀐다는 것은 사실이지만, 그것은
상대적 위상 차이라고 부르는 거예요.
이것은 글로벌 위상과 다른데, 전체 벡터에
복소수를 곱하는 것이 아니기 때문이에요.
그리고 이것은 우리가 이 상태들의 차이를 구별할 수 있다는 사실과 일치해요.
특히, Hadamard 연산을 적용하고
측정하면, 상태가 플러스 상태였으면 0을 보고
마이너스 상태였으면 1을 보게 돼요.
이 수업에서 볼 양자 정보의
다음 한계는 복제 불가능 정리예요.
여기 복제 불가능 정리의 한 가지 설명이 있는데,
이 특정 설명은 꽤 구체적이고 명확해서
이야기하기 더 쉬울 거예요. 복제 불가능 정리를 더 일반적으로 공식화하는 다른 방법들도 있지만,
지금은 이것에 집중할게요.
같은 고전적 상태 집합을 가진 두 시스템 X와 Y가 있다고 가정해요.
이것은 0부터 D-1까지의 정수로 구성되는데,
D는 최소 2예요.
고전적 상태의 이름이 무엇인지는 별로 중요하지 않지만, 이 이름을 선택하면 간단하게 유지하는 데 도움이 돼요.
여기서 가장 중요한 것은 최소 두 개의 다른
고전적 상태가 있다는 거예요. 다시 말해,
고전적 상태가 하나만 있는
자명하고 흥미롭지 않은 경우는
걱정하지 않는다는 거예요.
정리가 말하는 것은 X, Y에 적용할 수 있는 유니터리 연산 U가 없어서,
Y를 0 상태로 초기화하면
X의 임의의 양자 상태를 효과적으로
복사하거나 복제할 수 있는 것은 없다는 거예요.
여기 이 식을 단독으로 살펴보면,
모든 양자 상태 벡터 Psi에 대해,
Psi와 0 상태의 텐서 곱에 U를 적용하면,
Psi 텐서 Psi를 얻는다는 거예요.
다시 말해 Psi의 독립적인 두 복사본을 얻는다는 거예요.
그것이 양자 상태를 복제할 수 있다면의 의미이고,
정리가 말하는 것은 이것이 불가능하다는 거예요.
circuit의 관점에서 생각할 수 있는데,
정리가 말하는 것은 여기 보이는 것처럼
작동하는 gate나 circuit을 절대 만들 수 없다는 거예요.
상태 Psi의 복사본 하나가 초기화된 qubit 모음과 함께 들어가고 Psi의 두 복사본이 나오는 거예요.
특정 상태 Psi의 선택에 대해서는
이렇게 할 수 있지만, 모든 양자 상태 Psi에 대해
이런 식으로 작동하는 circuit은 절대 만들 수 없어요.
그것이 정리가 말하는 거예요.
이 정리를 증명하는 것은 꽤 쉬운데,
사실 본질적으로 우리가 찾는 변환이
선형이 아니라는 사실로 귀결돼요.
하지만 유니터리 연산은 선형이니까
그냥 작동할 수 없는 거예요.
여기 좀 더 자세한 논증이 있어요.
표준 기저 상태 Ket 0과
Ket 1을 복제하는 유니터리 연산 U가 있다고 가정해요.
D가 최소 2이기 때문에 고전적 상태 0과 1은
반드시 고전적 상태 집합에 속해야 해요.
하지만 이것은 선형성에 의해
X가 플러스 상태에 있으면, 이렇게 쓸 수 있는데,
결과는 여기 이 두 상태의 선형 결합이에요.
하지만 그것은 올바른 동작이 아니에요.
U에 대한 요구 사항은 U가 플러스 상태를 복제하는 것인데,
이것은 여기 이 등식이
만족되어야 한다는 뜻이에요.
이 두 상태는 같지 않아서
작동하지 않고, 그게 전부예요.
복제 불가능 정리에 대한
몇 가지 추가 설명이에요.
첫째, 이 복제 불가능 정리의 설명은
어떤 의미에서 절대적이에요.
이것처럼 정확히 작동하는 유니터리 연산 U가
존재하지 않는다고 단순히 말하는 거예요.
근사를 설명하는 어떤 방식에 대해
이것을 근사적으로 수행하는 유니터리 연산 U가
존재하는지 물을 수 있어요.
이 설명에 대한 근사예요. 관심을 가질 수 있는
다양한 근사의 개념들이 있고
시리즈의 세 번째 단원에서 몇 가지를
볼 거예요. 하지만 이런 다양한
근사의 개념들에 대해,
근사적으로 복제할 수 있는 정도에 강한 한계를 두는
복제 불가능 정리의 양적 설명이 있어요.
두 번째 언급은 표준 기저 상태를 복사하거나
복제하는 것은 확실히 가능하다는 거예요.
예를 들어, Controlled NOT gate는 qubit의 표준 기저 상태를 복사해요.
이것은 복제 불가능 정리와 모순되지 않아요.
요점은 복제 불가능 정리에서의 복제는 표준 기저 상태뿐만 아니라
모든 상태에 대해
작동해야 한다는 거예요.
Controlled NOT gate는 예를 들어
플러스 상태를 확실히 복제하지 못해요.
마지막으로, 확률적 상태에 대한 복제 불가능 정리도 있다는 점을 지적할 가치가 있어요.
그냥 사람들이 이야기하거나
관심을 갖는 것이 아닐 뿐이에요.
누군가가 무작위로 비트를 선택한다면,
예를 들어, 두 값에 확률을 할당하는
어떤 임의의 방법으로 선택하고
그 비트를 건네주면,
물론 그 무작위 비트의 독립적인 두 샘플을
얻을 방법이 없어요.
확률이 무엇인지
모르니까요.
Controlled NOT이 표준 기저 상태를 복사하는 것처럼 비트를 복사할 수는 있지만, 그것은 확률적 상태를 복제하는 것과 같은 것이 아니에요.
그렇게 할 만큼 충분한 정보가 없어요.
받은 무작위 비트가 확률이 무엇이었는지 알려주지 않거든요.
그냥 비트일 뿐이에요.
확률적 상태의 복제 불가능성은
양자 설정에서와 정확히 같은 추론에서 따라나와요.
복제는 비선형 과정인 반면, 확률적 연산은 유니터리 연산과 마찬가지로 선형이에요.
어쨌든, 확률적 상태를 복제할 수 없다는 것은
놀랍지 않고, 양자 상태를 복제할 수 없다는
사실만큼 흥미롭지는 않지만,
요점은 단순히 이것이 양자에만 특유한
현상이 아니라는 것을 관찰하는 거예요.
이 수업에서 논의할 양자 정보의 마지막 한계는
두 양자 상태가 직교하지 않으면 완벽하게
구별하는 것이 불가능하다는 거예요.
이것을 다르게 말하면, 두 양자 상태가
완벽하게 구별될 수 있다면
직교해야 한다는 거예요.
두 양자 상태 Psi와 Phi의 완벽한 구별이라고
할 때 의미하는 것은, 오류의 가능성 없이
구별할 수 있는 어떤 방법이 있다는 거예요.
오류의 가능성 없이요.
quantum circuit 모델의 관점에서, 이것을
화면에 보이는 것처럼 표현할 수 있어요.
어떤 유니터리 연산 U가 있는데, quantum circuit으로
구현할 수도 있고 U를 추상적으로
유니터리 연산으로 생각할 수도 있어요.
U의 입력으로 상태 Psi 또는 상태 Phi가
초기화된 qubit 묶음과 함께 들어가는데, 이것을 이 구별 과정을 어떤 식으로든 돕는 작업 공간 qubit으로 생각할 수 있어요.
U가 적용된 후, 맨 위 qubit을 표준 기저 측정으로 측정하고, 여기가 완벽한
구별 부분이에요.
입력 상태가 Psi였으면 측정이 결과 0을
100% 확률로 주어야 하고, 입력 상태가 Phi였으면,
측정이 결과 1을
다시 100% 확률로 주어야 해요.
U가 적용된 후 이 다른 qubit들의
상태가 무엇인지는 중요하지 않아요.
중요한 것은 측정에서 얻는 이 하나의 비트뿐인데, 그 비트가 두 상태 중 어느 것으로 시작했는지 알려주는 거예요.
특정 상태 Psi와 Phi의 선택에 대해, 이런 완벽한 구별이 가능할 수도 있고 불가능할 수도 있어요.
그리고 관찰할 것은 이것이 가능하려면
Psi와 Phi가 직교 상태여야 한다는 거예요.
이것은 Phi와 Psi가 직교하지 않으면
완벽하게 구별할 수 없다는 뜻이에요.
완벽한 구별이 직교성을 함의하는 이유를 살펴봅시다.
이 두 다이어그램이 표현하는 것을 나타내는
두 등식을 적는 것부터 시작할게요.
상태 Psi와 함께 초기화된 qubit 묶음에 U를 적용한 후 얻는 양자 상태를 생각하면,
여기 이런 형태여야 하는데, Pi 제로는
맨 위 qubit을 제외한 모든 qubit의 상태를 나타내는
어떤 양자 상태 벡터예요.
이 양자 상태 Pi 제로에 대한 정보가 없어요.
아무것이나 될 수 있어요.
하지만 전체 상태가 이렇게 보여야 한다는 것은 알고 있는데,
측정이 결과 0을 100% 확률로
주는 것이 보장되는 유일한 방법이기 때문이에요.
두 번째에 대해서도 유사한
등식이 있어요.
이번에는 맨 위 qubit이 1 상태에 있어야 하고,
Pi 제로와 마찬가지로 Pi 1 상태는 아무것이나 될 수 있어요.
Pi 1에 대한 정보가 없는 것 외에,
Pi 제로와 Pi 1 사이의 관계에 대해서도 아무것도 몰라요.
아는 한에서는, 이것들은 그냥
두 임의의 양자 상태예요.
다음으로 할 수 있는 것은 이 등식의 양변에
U 대거, 즉 U의 켤레 전치를 곱하는 거예요.
그렇게 하면 여기 보이는
두 등식을 얻어요.
U 대거 곱하기 U가 항등 행렬이라는 사실을 사용하고 있어요.
그래서 어느 등식의 좌변에도 U나 U 대거가 보이지 않는 거예요.
이제 Psi와 Phi 사이의 내적을 생각할 수 있어요.
이것은 Psi와 Phi의 내적에 0 상태와
자기 자신의 내적을 곱한 것과 같아요.
어떤 상태와 자기 자신의 내적은 1이고,
0 상태도 마찬가지이기 때문이에요.
두 등식을 보면, 여기 이 식이 두 등식으로 표현되는 벡터들의 내적과 같다는 것을 알 수 있어요.
특히 이 등식들의 좌변들 사이의 내적이에요.
좌변이 우변과 같으니까, 이 내적을
이 등식들의 우변으로 표현되는
벡터들의 내적으로도 표현할 수 있어요.
왜냐하면 두 등식 모두에서
좌변이 우변과 같으니까요.
여기 이 식을 얻는데, 이것은 두 등식의 우변의 내적이거나, 동치적으로
첫 번째의 켤레 전치를 두 번째에 곱한 것이에요.
U 곱하기 U 대거는 U가 유니터리이기 때문에
항등 행렬과 같아서 사라져요.
조금 정리하면 이 내적들의
곱을 얻을 수 있어요.
Pi 제로와 Pi 1 사이의 관계에 대해
아무것도 모른다는 것을 기억하세요.
그래서 이들의 내적이 무엇인지 몰라요.
우리에게는 미스터리예요. 하지만 그것이 무엇이든, Ket 0과 Ket 1의 내적에 곱하는 건데, 그것은 0이에요.
그래서 최종 결과로 0을 얻는데,
그것이 보이고 싶었던 거예요. Psi와 Phi 사이의
내적이 0이에요.
그래서 두 상태는 직교해요.
직교하지 않는 두 양자 상태를
완벽하게 구별하려고 시도하지 마세요. 그냥 할 수 없어요.
방금 증명한 설명에 대한 역도 있는데,
직교하는 양자 상태는 항상 완벽하게 구별할 수 있다는 거예요.
이것은 수업 앞부분에서 언급한
사실을 활용하면 보기 어렵지 않아요.
구체적으로, Psi와 Phi가 직교 상태이면,
할 수 있는 것 중 하나는 처음 두 열이
이 두 상태인 유니터리 행렬 U를 선택하는 거예요.
이것이 항상 가능하다는 것을 알고 있고
이 과제를 위해 이 유니터리 행렬이 정확히
어떻게 선택되는지는 중요하지 않아요.
중요한 것은 이것들이 처음 두 열이라는 거예요.
추가 qubit이 필요 없어요. 두 가능한 상태에
U를 적용하면 이 두 가능한
결과를 얻게 돼요.
맨 위 qubit을 측정하면, 이것이 맨 오른쪽 qubit이라는 것을 기억하세요, 0 또는 1을 얻게 되는데
어떤 상태로 시작했는지에 따라 달라요.
대안적으로, 여기 보이는 것처럼 정의된
0과 1이라는 결과를 가진 사영 측정을 고려할 수 있어요.
이 경우, 측정은
실제로 Psi에만 의존해요.
이 측정은 Psi를 Psi에
직교하는 어떤 상태와도 완벽하게 구별해요.
이 사영 측정으로 Psi를 측정하면,
이 등식들이 보여주듯이
결과 0을 확률 1로 얻어요.
그리고 Psi에 직교하는 어떤 상태 Phi에 대해서는
결과 1을 확률 1로 얻어요.
이 계산의 세부 사항은 살펴보지 않을 건데,
관심이 있으시면 직접 세부 사항을
살펴보시길 권해요.
이것으로 수업 3이 끝나요. 이 수업에서는
quantum circuit을 포함해서 많은 내용을 다뤘어요.
내적과 직교정규성, 사영과 사영 측정, 글로벌 위상이 중요하지 않다는 사실,
복제 불가능 정리, 그리고 직교하지 않는 상태는 완벽하게 구별할 수 없지만 직교하는 상태는 가능하다는 사실을 다뤘어요.
곧 네 번째 수업에서 만나길 바라요.
이것은 시리즈의 첫 번째 단원의
마지막 수업이에요.
네 번째 수업에서는 세 가지 매우 중요한
예에 대해 이야기할 거예요. 텔레포테이션, 초밀집 코딩,
그리고 CHSH 부등식, 또는 때때로 설명되는 CHSH 게임에 대해서요.
그때까지 안녕히 계세요.